1094 if you're in doubt of the scripture
then is is this the one that you're
speaking of you you don't you don't have
to jump in on his uh on his argument you
want to bring up something new no no
he's he's on the right track you just
got frustrated and you ra quit on him
1094 is that what happened back back in
the time what was the what was the right
track that he was you believe in
progressive revelation what was the
right track that he was on
it was on the right track you just raged
qu what what was that what was the right
track he was trying to read the the
verse for you and explain to you what
they meant by doubts no he wasn't that's
not what he was doing it's so it it it
cracks me up
or it cracks me just one one second I am
it's it cracks me up every this happens
all the time the next Muslim will come
up and say you misunderstood what he was
saying he cooked you you know he
answered you I didn't say you
misunderstood you you say what he was
saying but you say that you you say
nothing that he was saying you didn't
let him continue I'm just trying to
continue yeah there's there's there's a
level of dishonesty where I choose to
stop at if you're if you're dishonest
that that that that's that's with
respect to you with all due respect
you're not a Muslim scholar nor do you
understand the text that he's talking
about so back back in the time of the
Prophet according to the Muslims they
say that I know more about Islam than
most Muslims in the world okay cool mad
anyway that's that's what they
say Okay moving forward I I don't know
who which which one's saying that cuz I
can pull if I was to go through you want
you want me to pull it up and show you
where they said that no no I don't care
who said what whether it's a Muslim a
group it it was a group of them we can
we can pull we can like I I understand
that you're fairly well researched into
straw man arguments that you put up on
your life you said researched into straw
man
arguments yes what what's a St what's a
St
man arguments that really don't have
much significant at
all that's not a it's not a strawman
argument that's that's more like a a red
herring than
a in no no no you said you said you said
that I specialize in straw man arguments
that means you know what it is what's
what's bur in St man argument yeah
what's what's a St man what's a strong
man argument what's a St man continue
yeah we can continue when we know what a
St man the first point that we're
talking about Osama what is a stman
argument what is a stman a a strongman
argument that it's an argument that
falls apart really
quickly oh so so so a Muslim argument no
not all right brother look if you're
going to if this is how you you oh oh
you you can't you can't take it huh you
you could you could jab but you can't
take it at all can you brother you're
the one who's raging I'm trying to
continue the conversation I'm just
matching energy with energy I'm just
showing you your stupidity no you're not
you're I'm trying to continue the
conversation when you come here and you
jab and you dis be ready to take it be
ready to be ready to take it you said I
you set the tone here brother you set
the tone here Habibi you set the tone
okay I'm following your lead man all
right bro look so 1094 talks
[Laughter]
about my boy because he heard you skip
right past
this yeah we're talking about nothing
let me I'm going let you continue but
let me just tell you what a straw man is
okay a straw man argument is when you
misrepresent the person's argument the
you're talking to you misrepresent what
they say you misrepresent their argument
hold on you misrepresent their argument
and then you attack the
misrepresentation that you created
that's what a straw man do that's
literally what you do okay give me an
example I can't give you an example of
you said I specializ it you said you see
my all my streams that when I do that
come on no I didn't say all your streams
I've I've been on your streams a couple
of times and I've seen the way you you
you create an argument then you
misrepresent the whole text and then you
keep pressing on it so hard like as
though it's a fact okay let's see if
this happens today with you okay so now
can we continue yes yes go ahead
hopefully I don't sh
that all right so
109 I can't hear you if you're off the
app can you hear me I can hear you now
so you've read the verse 1094 where it
says if you're in doubt then speak to
those who are let's who read the book
read the book before you know I can I
can quote a Verbatim for you it's okay
if you're in doubt if you're in doubt
who are these people the ver the verse
tells you if you are in doubt about what
we have revealed to you then go and ask
the people who've been reading the
scripture before you be not of those who
doubt yes now do you know who these
people who these people are the Jews and
the Christians
no not just any Jew or any
Christian so these are the people who
are Scholars of the time who have been
have been given Revelation
and have the truthful Revelation in
terms of progressive revelation nice not
this sorry I said that's nice what
what's what's the point of this this has
nothing to do with the argument do you
even know what the argument is what's
what's what what was my argument with
this verse the point of this is what
existed back then is not what you have
in your hands right now no worries no
worries what was the point of my
argument with this
verse the point of your AR I actually
can't even remember to be honest so you
don't even know what you're about what
you're addressing you want to instead of
I was continuing off the other brothers
if you're continuing off of the other
brother's point then you know what point
he was about to hold on then you know
don't interrupt me please if you were
continuing off the other brother's point
then you know what point hey man if you
if you interrupt me again you're you're
out just simple as that you're showing
you're being rude now I let you speak I
didn't interrupt you so have some
decorum I don't want to kick you I want
us to
talk all right go ah appreciate
appreciate it if you are addressing or
uh just continuing the point that the
past brother was on then that means that
you know the point that he was
addressing how can you continue his
point if you don't even know what he was
addressing the problem is that me and
you engaged in some sort of dialogue
that kind of made me I knew exactly what
part I was talking about when it when it
came to the verse I came up here to
explain that and then the dialogue that
we had in between that that useless
stuff that we were speaking about kind
of made me forget most of the things
that we were speaking about so let me
give it to you again okay so you canly
address I'm trying to help you I'm
trying to help you so here's the point
here's the point that you need to
address I brought this verse because it
shows that it's the previous scriptures
that verify the Quran not the other way
around then how does that help you oh
previous scriptures that verify the
Quran not the other way around no not
true okay so what is the point of Allah
sending Muhammad to the previous
scriptures if he has doubt
what's the point of that again so the
the the scripture that was presented
down to the prophet s wasallam he was at
the earlier times of his Propet I don't
care what's the point of him going to
the previous scriptures if he has
doubts if I can continue please answer
the question don't waffle on nothing
that I didn't ask I didn't ask about
Muhammad's beginnings and his him being
a new Prophet I didn't ask that
you take do you take question do you
take answers without context or I I take
direct answers within the context so the
direct answer is the reason why Allah
had him go to the previous scriptures
with to to for his doubt is because boom
that's not what happened that's and this
is what I mean you are now misre
representing the
verse if you have doubts about what has
been revealed to you then go and ask the
people who've been reading the scripture
before you Allah's talking to Muhammad
right yes and Allah tells Muhammad if he
has doubts about what's been revealed
meaning the Quran right if he has doubts
about the Quran right no not meaning the
Quran no oh then what what's been
revealed about his Revelation what's
been revealed to
Muhammad the the full the full Quran
wasn't revealed to Muhammad at this time
but what is being revealed to
him there's re progressive revelation
Revelation that's coming down in what
Revelation in what in terms of his
prophethood and his mission is that in
what book
what do you mean in what in the Quran ah
so when it says if you are in doubt
about what we have revealed to you means
the Quran right even if it's not the
whole Quran pie is up to this point what
we've revealed to you concerning the
Quran so far right yes okay we can we
can move with that okay so if you have
doubts about the
Quran go and ask the people who've been
reading the scripture before you
yes
why because there are people who in the
scripture previously so in the previous
scriptures came across the same message
who came across the same sort of things
that happened within Revelation okay and
these people can can confirm and give
Comfort but that doesn't so they can so
they can so they can
verify that what he has receiv they yeah
not to verify the Quran well no it is
the Quran because he's have because it's
doubt about the Quran that's about thean
Prophet at the end of the day is a man
Osama that's that's not here there Osama
that's not here nor there it's about the
Revelation which is the Quran we already
agreed to that do not take 10 steps back
it's it's about the Quran keep cutting
me off well stop switching stay on the
point I'm not switching okay then stay
the point it's about the Quran that
might he might be doubts right if you're
in doubt he not talking about in doubt
of the book you're talking about himself
if he's got doubts all right I'm I'm G
do this one last time I'm G do this one
last time One Last
Time doubts doubts about what Osama
doubts about
what in terms of himself so he's inner
feelings what he feel got it so it says
if you are in doubt oh Muhammad about
what you feel about your self then go
ask the people who've been reading the
scripture before you is that what it
says STW men do you see who's the one
straw mening the verse now guys who is
the one that is strawmanning the Quran
verse now I couldn't is it me or is it
explaining it to you I can't even finish
explaining it to you is it me or you
who's now strawmanning the Quran who's
twisting what the Quran says and making
an argument over it thanks for coming
thanks for coming you you haven't let me
thanks for coming you're right you're
done thanks for
coming thanks for coming it happens like
this every time Avery God logic good
logic good logic you're the one who's
misrepresenting the Quran and then
you're hammering you're hammering us
with the Quran with this
misrepresentation of the verse you
twisted the verse and you twisted the
words and you're trying to make an
argument based off of
that I'm not doing a Justice here guys
I'm not doing it justice let me put it
on the screen so that everybody can see
who's the one that misrepresents it and
stats the
Quran and it
says so if you are in doubt
concerning what you feel on the inside
of wait hold on it doesn't say that if
you're in
doubt concerning yourself and your inner
thought wait it doesn't say that either
dang it I keep I'm sorry guys I keep
string the verse on accident it's just
like it's automatic sorry I need to get
out of this habit Subhan Allah please
get me out of this habit of strawmanning
misrepresenting and twisting the words
of your of your of your Quran oh
Allah okay let me start
over here it
is so if you are in doubt concerning
that which we have revealed unto
you oh so nothing about what he's
feeling on the inside nothing about his
own doubts about him what what he can do
with women nothing about his what doubts
with his like low self-esteem he's not
secure enough within
himself doubts about the
Revelation that Allah is giving
him what's he supposed to do
he's supposed to go and talk to the
people who have been
reading the book before
him the
Bible what's the only thing we do here
y'all because apparently we have new
guests
here apparently we have people who have
never he says he's seen the stream I
doubt it I I don't think he's ever seen
the stream before cuz he doesn't he
doesn't know our motto he don't know our
motto ladies and gentlemen what's the
only thing we
do that's
it that's
it that's it that's all y'all got
it we we just read
man we just going to read
man that's the only thing we do
here there isn't a
second there isn't a
moment where you're going to see me not
reading there's not a second where
you're going to see me add to the
text where you're going to see me try to
interpret the text in my own lens we
just go read
that's it